hey David is there an advantage to
Democrats announcing presidential runs
earlier well there's two ways to answer
that question is there an advantage
within the Democratic primary to the
Democrats that announced early like
Elizabeth Warren and then there's the
kind of bigger picture question which is
are Democrats better off starting their
primary earlier rather than later
now it's not really starting earlier
like that ship has sailed because this
is when we start to see typically about
a year what is it a year and a year and
nine months before the election that's
usually when you start to see the
exploratory committees and you have some
early candidates so it's not actually
early it sort of feels maybe like it is
because a very prominent Democrat in
Elizabeth Warren has said basically I'm
running I'm forming an exploratory
committee and and this is something that
that I'm interested in doing so I think
the answer is it depends unfortunately
if there is a particularly ugly primary
and despite starting early it's not
resolved who the nominee is going to be
any earlier that may be damaging to
Democrats overall okay so we'll answer
the macro question first if early
announcements California moving their
primary up in the 2020 election cycle
which we thought we've also talked about
the restructuring of the super delegate
process if all of these circumstances
lead to the winner of the Democratic
primary being determined earlier I do
think that that is net better for
Democrats in the general election it
does allow for Trump or whoever is the
eventual Republican nominee to have more
time to attack that person but I still
think it's a net benefit because you've
more quickly moved to the message for
the 2020 general election now if the DNC
screws it up if Democrats screw it up
which they well could they screw up
stuff all the time then it's not going
to be particularly beneficial so at the
macro level I think resolving the
Democratic nominee earlier would be
beneficial all else being equal then
let's look at the micro within the
democratic
primary are you better off if you
announce early I don't think it really
makes a difference as long as you're not
allowed announcing too late because it's
all about name recognition really there
is a guy who I mean this kind of
explains it I think it's Delaney
Maryland congressman I think and this is
part of the problem he announced in 2018
I barely know a thing about him I
researched him when he announced I
didn't find him particularly compelling
or interesting he's been in this thing
for a long time elizabeth warren
announces and she's getting the lion's
share of the attention because she has
more name recognition and is more
prominent so i actually don't think
within a reasonable range that there's
much of an advantage to announcing early
the exception to this is the question
mark around bernie and some of the folks
who are close to Bernie that I spoke to
in 2018 actually said to me we are
considering whether we take damage there
whether we are at a disadvantage so to
speak if Bernie plans to run but
Elizabeth Warren announces first because
they are the two of them the most
progressive senators in the Senate at
this time so that is an open question
for me and I do think that if Bernie is
going to run he should not wait more
than another month or two before
announcing because otherwise you do let
Elizabeth Warren get sort of established
as the progressive senator who is in the
race and then I think Bernie is coming
from behind beyond that I think that
it's name recognition Joe Biden as
someone who is not in there as an
Elizabeth Warren or Bernie Sanders if he
announced next month or he announced in
June I don't think it makes a big
difference in the grand scheme of things
if you disagree with my take on either
of these elements the macro of the
Democratic primary versus the general
election and the micro of the Democratic
primary let me know and we can do a
follow up next week or whatever great
bonus show for you today China is going
to be landing on the far side of the
Moon single-use foam has been banned in
New York City businesses as of January
1st and also interesting recruiting
tactics being employed by the British
Army we will talk about all of those
stories and more on today
bonus show get access to the bonus show
by becoming a member sign up at WWDC
2014 you can also become a patron at at
least the $5 a month level
patreon.com slash david pakman show
don't miss the bonus show it's great
overhyped as someone said but worth the
price of membership or patronage